making his third consecutive opening day
or opening night start it is marco
gonzalez gonzalez it's really turned
into one of the best left-handers in the
american league runner at first here is
mike yasremski left-handed hitter runner
at first slater gets a lead here's the
set by gonzalez and now the pitch the
ostremski swing and a miss for strike
three just kind of hacked it a pitch up
and in
so right away marco gonzalez has his
first strike out of the season the giant
starter making his second career opening
day start it is kevin gausman coming off
his excellent year
in 2020 and that'll bring up designated
hitter ty france and this kid man had a
tremendous spring
three and two pitch and a splitter is
top slowly up third base side over to
get it with a slide as gosman then from
his knees turns and throws over to first
in time don't score inning number two
evan longoria first ball swinging hits a
drive deep into right field way back
there still going and
goodbye
a home run for longoria
and the giants have a one-nothing lead
mongoria first ball swinging to the
opposite field
posey opted out of last year's season
for health and safety reasons they had
newly adopted daughters
in the unusual spot in the order hitting
seventh
supposedly hit 286 only 21 official at
bats all spring
and he swings and knee belts one deep
into left field way back there it is off
the top of the wall and then over the
wall into the bullpen
so buster posey after missing all of
last year
hits a home run in his first at-bat in
his return to the giants
well here he is third baseman evan
longoria jumped on the first pitch
leading off the second a home run to
right field an opposite field shot for
longoria
checks the runner at first the 0-1 pitch
curve swung on line drive base hit right
center field solano the second will make
the turn head for three up of the ball
is tremel the throwing to second base to
crawford down with the tagging out at
second base is longoria
holy smokes what a throw by the rookie
taylor trammell here's wilmer flores oh
for one his flight out
to right field
here's the 2-1 pitch
flores rips this one down the left field
line that is a base hit and it's rolling
into the corner to be extra bases for
wilmer flores in to score donovan solano
over the third belt he stops there as
the ball is relayed back in by fraley
into second with an rbi double wilmer
flores
three-nothing giants
second and third two down
with crawford coming up
here's the stretch
now the 2-2 pitch on the way crawford to
swing little tapping to the right side
of the mound picked up by gonzalez
marcos throw to first in time to get
crawford nettled in the inning damage
control done by gonzalez the giants get
the one and that's it we head to the
bottom of the fourth
here's first baseman evan white
and he can really take a chunk out of
that three-run deficit with one swing in
the back giants three mariners nothing
in the fourth inning with two outs
seeger at second giants
playing white on the pull side on the
infield the opposite way in the outfield
one-two pitch right there on the outside
corner 97 miles an hour strike three
call
and here comes the lead off man austin
slater now the three in one pinch
swing and there's a drive in the right
field drifting back hanniger at the
warning track at the wall he jumps it's
over his head and over the wall
the first home run of the year for
austin slater that just barely crept
over the wall in right field and it is
four nothing giants
so here's brandon belt he has flied out
deep to right
he sent hanniger back within what three
or four feet of the right field wall
with a deep fly ball in the second
inning then he walked in the fourth
left-handed hitter two men on two men
out and the curveball is lined down the
right field line a base hit coming
around third solano he'll score heading
for third longoria he'll stop there and
belt holds on with a single as haneker
runs the ball down over near the foul
line and fires it into second base
so five to nothing giants runners at
first and third two runs have scored in
the inning and here is wilmer flores
the stretch and the left-handers 2-1
pitch
to flores swung on and it's popped up
second baseman dylan moore off to his
left coming in toward the cut of the
grass between first and second he's
there and makes the catch and that'll
end the inning but the giants tack on
two more halfway point we had to the
bottom of the fifth runner at third one
out for dylan moore who's
struck out looking and a liner off the
glove of guzman right to the second
baseman to throw him out on 1-4-3
cosmon sets pitches
swinging a broken back fly ball softly
hit into center field tracked down by
dubon white tagging here he comes throw
coming home it's not even close it's up
the first base line
dylan moore with a sacrifice fly into
center field and he has put the mariners
on the board and the bottom of the
seventh
5-1 giant
longoria has been on base three times
3-2 pitch strike three called he gets
longoria looking how about that will
vest major league debut strikes out the
very first batter that he faces a
veteran like evan longoria caught
looking two on it two outs for the
giants here in the top of the eighth
they lead it five to one that'll bring
up shortstop brandon crawford
now here's the pitch to crawford
grounded into the hold it short far to
his right goes j.p crawford to get it
and his throne of first is in the dirt
and it shoots right on by
white the first baseman he could not
handle it flores is going to score and
buster posey goes to third
giants pick up a run at six to one
posey at third crawford on at first base
on the battery center fielder mauricio
de vaughn the 3-2 pitch swung on fly
ball into left center field fraley going
back jake is there and he makes the
catch and that will retire the side will
best major league debut gives up a run
but it's an honored run here in the
eighth we go to the bottom of the eighth
hour score
it's now the giant six and the mariners
won but here is ty france and he could
do some chipping away with a
big swing in the bat right here against
whistler
and the one-two on the way to france and
here she comes swinging i'll fly ball
into shallow center field that's gonna
drop in for a base hit rounding third
and heading home is crawford he will
score and challenge the throw by deuban
goes into second base
ty france with an rbi single drives in a
run here in the bottom of the eighth
inning it's now the giant six and the
mariners two
so one away and here is center fielder
taylor trammell
what a spot for this kid now the stretch
and again the 3-2 pitch on the way to
taylor and it's outside for ball four
and that will force it a run taylor
trammell
picks up his first major league rbi
right hand hitting dylan moore coming in
we'll get
taylor rogers coming in 6-3
giants with the mariners threatening
mason loaded one out here's the pitch on
the way swinging a line drive down the
right feet line a fair ball into the
corner here comes france on the score
seeger ronnie third he will score around
to third goes trimel more in its second
with a two-run double it's a one-run
ball game it's now the giant six and the
mariners five dylan moore
and the batter
will be jose marmaleo's up to pinch it
for tom murphy so here is marmaleo's
for his first at-bat of the 20-21 season
the stretch and the 0-1 pitch swinging a
ground ball to first up of the ball is
belt down to second for one no the ball
gets on by crawford behind him two runs
are going to score the mariners have the
lead seven to six holy smokes i don't
believe it and now there's two outs for
the mariners here in the bottom of the
eighth inning
and that'll bring up mitch haniger
marmalejos gets ready to take off from
first
there he goes the pitch is swung on and
in the air into center field over to his
right a little bit goes
dubon and he's got it
and the inning is over and it looks like
alex dickerson is going to come up as a
pinch hitter for austin slater to try to
get a giants rally in the ninth inning
started
again the o2 pitch
swing
and the ball hit into right center field
deep way back there and
what gabe kepler was hoping for has
happened
his pinch hitter blasts a home run to
tie this game
wow
it is seven to seven
buster posey
posey sat out all of last year he opted
out of the season
the savage sets right by the chin
deals
swinging a lazy fly ball right field
haniker having to pick up some speed
near the line he slides in mitch haniger
makes the catch to end the top of the
10th
what a play
it is up to jake fraley now nobody out
base is loaded
[Applause]